this is a production of Cornell
University
we're here to Cornell orchards in early
August we want to talk about sampling
plants for Leif analysis we find that
leaves sampled at this time of the year
give us a much better indication of the
nutritional status of the plants then
would a soil test taking at any time of
the year because the leaves are actually
measuring what's taken up into the plant
and incorporated also if we sample the
plants too early in the spring the
levels are fluctuating dramatically
because the plants are growing so fast
or producing fruit and the levels just
aren't consistent from one week to the
other but if we wait until August things
kind of settle down and stabilize it's a
much better time and also if we wait too
much to that towards the end of the
season then the nutrients start being
taken back into the plant down into the
roots so we don't get very good readings
either so late July early August is
usually the ideal time for almost all of
our fruit crops
so here we are in a blueberry planning
and we want to look at a plant to take
leaves from so the question is what are
the best leaves to take that most
represent the nutritional status of the
plant and the answer is for blueberries
and for all plants is the most recently
fully expanded leads so on this
blueberry plant the shoot started
growing this year from this point it's
grown up to here these leaves of the tip
are the youngest leaves they're not very
representative the leaves at the bottom
are a couple of months old now they're
not very representative either the
leaves we want to take our those in this
zone right here the most recently fully
expanded leaves so these are the leaves
we would take four leaf analysis now we
want to take all the leaves off to shoot
like that I mean that's not really what
we want to do we want a randomly sample
throughout the planning so we might take
one or two leaves from this shoot one or
two leave some other shoot on this plant
but then move around the planning and
sample leaves from this position
throughout the planning until we get a
good representative sample on
strawberries we also want to select them
most recently fully expanded leaf and on
a plant like this some of these leaves a
little bit older you fold those down
look at the crown and pick the youngest
leaf that's just about fully expanded so
in that case it would be the sleep here
and again you would collect about 50 of
these leaves in a serve a random pattern
throughout the planning and again best
results will be obtained if you could do
that for one variety as opposed to
mixing your varieties on raspberries and
blackberries is important to distinguish
the floor canes from the prime mccain's
because when we leave sample we only
want to select leaves from the primer
canes so this is a for king because it
produced fruit this year and out
starting to die the leaves are turning
yellow and so that doesn't make a very
good representative sample the
nutritional status of the planning
instead we go to the prime Akane's which
represent this year's current growth we
look at the Keene and we again want to
select the most recently expanded leaves
so those are not the leaves here these
aren't fully expanded yet the plants
still growing the leaves down here are
older so we want to take the leaves from
this zone here because these are fully
expanded into the most recent because
the plant is growing in this direction
so we would again take a couple of
leaves from that section of a primate
cane and in the same thing from another
prime mccain and probably 50 primer
canes and a planning would be a good
representative sample for blackberries
we want to distinguish between the floor
cage which have fruit and the prime
Akane's don't have fruit we want to
sample from the prime Akane's the most
recently expanded leaves not in this
section here because these are still in
the process of expanding want a sample
from this section of the king here which
has the most fully expanded leaves into
the youngest since the plan is growing
an instruction so we would take maybe a
leave from here and a leave from here
and do that with maybe 50 prom at Cannes
and a planning
you're most consistent results are going
to be obtained when you can sample from
the same variety of the same age
obviously if you mix varieties the
numbers are going to vary a little bit
more they're not going to be as
consistent the same way if you sample
plans from different ages so under an
ideal situation the same variety the
same age but we understand it oftentimes
growers have mixed plantings with mixed
varieties and mixed ages and you don't
want to take 10 or 20 samples from a
single planning so the choices are you
know this sample from multiple varieties
multiple ages and get a bulk composite
sample and see if you're in the ballpark
or just pick one of the varieties and
assume that's going to represent the
nutritional level the other plans what
is sometimes done though if there's a
section of your field that looks
particularly problematic the leaves are
discolored the plants aren't growing
well enough there you should sample from
that section of field separately from
the rest of the field that's healthy
then we can compare the two and it gives
us a really good idea diagnostically
what might be going on what's different
between the affected area and the
unaffected area it might be pathogenic
it might be an herbicide residue but if
its nutritional will be able to pick
that up by looking at the leaves in the
affected area and outside the affected
area
these leaves should be washed off
preferably in distilled water if we use
regular tap water sometimes when that
dries the deposits calcium on the leaves
and then we might get an erroneous
reading if we watch it with distilled
water and then we these are going to be
dried when they get to the lab so you
can dry them too they don't have to be
kept moist they can use we put in a
paper bag put in the windowsill for a
few days until you can send them in they
go into the lab and they get dried and
then within a few days they can tell you
what the nutrient levels are in these
leaves and we have recommendations that
we can look at and say here are the
levels in your leaves here's what they
should be and we can make
recommendations as to what you need to
do to correct any problem it might exist
if you do the leaf analysis now this
time of the year you'll get
recommendations back and a lot of those
recommendations can be acted on in the
fall actually late falls a very good
time to be putting fertilizer on your
plant because it gives it time to work
into the soil and be available to be
taken up by the roots in the spring
nitrogen is the only nutrient team you
usually don't put on in the fall we
usually wait for spring to do that when
you go back your leaf analysis it will
give you values for maybe 13 essential
nutrients one of which is nitrogen
they'll be phosphorus potassium calcium
magnesium and the list goes on and the
recommendations for almost everything
can be applied in the fall wait till
spring for nitrogen
you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu